comment vaincre la solitude et le stress
pendant le confinement
ça c'est une question qui revient
énormément c'est vrai que ne rien
moralement beaucoup de français voilà
vont être en difficulté ce soir ils vont
prendre un coup au moral surtout ceux
qui peuvent pas ouvrir leur magasin tout
surtout les restaurateurs tous ces gens
là qui ont dit bah voilà à partir de
vendredi vous restez à la maison ça va
être extrêmement difficile pour eux
d'autant plus je vais vous dire moi ce
que je pense sacha au lit c'est pour ces
gens là ça va être encore plus difficile
que le premier confinement pas ce qu'ils
vont voir tous les autres allaient
travailler en entreprise
ils vont voir que la vie continue exact
que justement ils sont sur le bord de la
route avec diniz nous on se retrouve
alors que tout le monde travaille encore
alors ça a été dur en mars avril mai 10
est bon c'est le cas pour tout le monde
personne n'a travaillé que ce soit mon
pote qui travaille dans une entreprise
où mon pote voilà où un autre pote voilà
qui fait autre chose là aujourd'hui et
on dira tout ce on a l'impression d'être
il vendit on a l'impression d'être des
pestiférés au kremlin à la maison ça
moralement ça va être très compliqué
alors vous en avez conscience
d'abord on en a conscience et c'est le
message des parts de vivre quand on dit
protéger les français et protéger tous
les français et le message aussi les de
dire qu'on a progressivement alors en
mars il ya eu l'effet de sidération où
tout était fermé du jour au lendemain et
puis progressivement
il ya plutôt une liste de métiers qui
étaient autorisées soit parce qu'ils
étaient jugés essentiels et le critère
il est là en fait pourquoi c'est pas la
boutique d'habillement alors que dans le
service public hospitalier y compris
quand on a des personnes contaminées et
parce qu'on n'a pas assez de personnes
bar on ouvre quand même parce que c'est
un service public
c'est une fonction essentielle pour
notre pays beaucoup là on y est
contraint et donc progressivement on a
réouvert en retrait des listes ces
listes elle figure c'est notre base de
départ base de travail sur ce
confinement là mais le mode essentiel
subi un dur grand cynisme c'est
peut-être pas essentiel pour les clients
mais c'est essentiel pour les gens qui
ont les magasins oui le mode essentiel
il est très malheureux
mais peut-être que je me laisserais
après aussi bien sûr on va en parler
avec lui c'est pour ça que il ya tout
tout volet économique qui étaient
déployés qui a été précis c'est à dire
que les edge était de 1500 euros par
mois ces 10000 euros
dorénavant mais les pgs qui sont
toujours là les annulations de
cotisations elles sont encore là c'est
sûr ça c'est le fondement non s'est
ouverte au maximum la réclusion
mais l'accompagnement moral c'est aussi
long les à personne c'est là qu'ils ont
des restaurants et des bars existe c'est
fini pour moi avec des temps de travail
et pris qui petit si j'ai eu 20 ans de
travail qui s'en vont et sûre d'elle
même si c'est bien de faire l'aide et
l'aide a sûrement entendu si vous voulez
redonner au jeudi on est on est
certainement le pays est le mieux loti
rendez vous des acteurs philippe
douste-blazy et laurent ça y est vous
pourrez me confirmer moi ça c'est sûr
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de gens
qui malgré les aides on pourra pas tenir
on va devoir se refermer ya des gens qui
ont investi pendant des années des
années dans un restaurant dans un bar
dans une salle de sport parce que mal de
sport ces terminaux ti qui vont dire
c'est terminé pour moi ce film je pense
qu'elle est extrêmement important et au
fond c'est comment éviter qu'une crise
économique devienne une crise sociale
c'est ça extrêmement grave avec tout ce
que ça représente d'ailleurs un terme
médical derrière et précis en suisse et
dans les prestations suicide à des
sanctions suicide sur cette annexion
alors les mesures que je voudrais aussi
en fait profiter du fait que j'ai la
parole pour dire qu' il faudrait pas que
la suite de ce confinement on puisse
voir pendant les vacances de noël
ce que moi j'ai vu pendant cet été
qu'est-ce que vous avez vous en gros une
fois que le confinement était terminé et
ça tout le monde aurait explosé oasis et
la fête on a fait la fête
non non non je dis plus d'un je dis ça
parce que c'est extrêmement grave
évidemment ce que je dis mais mais je
pèse mes mots je pense qu'il est
important d'avoir cette période
extrêmement difficile très bien qu'il
sera difficile pour tout le monde de
mettre des dizaines des 20 30 40 50 cent
millions de tests le plus vite possible
antigénique rapide et aussi expliquer et
surtout aux personnes les plus âgées
ceux qui ont des comorbidités qu'il faut
prendre leurs responsabilités et ensuite
ré ouvrir le plus vite possible parce
que c'est dans ce pays va continuer à
disparaître si on continue à le confiner
de cette manière